degorio cinema revenge al elahh Frank
tu peux m'appeler le docteur je suis celui
qui t'a opéré et la raison pour laquelle
est simple tu as tué mon frère cette
opération ton rappel de la
chose terrible que tu as faite
je t'ai libéré de la
prison macho toi  J'ai vécu de la chance
Frank c'est votre opportunité de rachat
ouais pour moi Freight J'ai besoin de me vider la
tête
Frank a l'air un peu différent pour dire que
j'ai été embauché pour faire ce travail
le MA voulait même
pourquoi moi le médecin te voulait  le gars que vous avez
poussé ici il y a c'était une affaire de famille que je
voulais appeler ça Frank cuisine énorme
douleur psychique besoin de parler à ce
médecin
gagner sa vie comme j'ai fait une chose est
sûre que le changement va venir alors
essayez de vous comprendre et  puis fait
assez de problèmes Vénus
je t'ai donné une nouvelle chance illumination
tu as perdu du temps
il reste quelque chose à encadrer la
cuisine c'était son objectif à bout portant
chirurgies courantes revenger
phénomènes de levin ego massif vidéo mode LED
mouvement exclusif
[Musique]